Головна порада, що робити зараз - це не панікувати.
А також дотримуватися дуже простих правил:
Поменше виходити з будинку.
Завжди при першій можливості мити руки і дезинфікувати їх.
Якщо немає дезинфекторів - 70% розчин спирту.
Намагайтеся не чіпати обличчя брудними руками
Потурбуйтеся про тих, кому понад 60 років.
Ці люди у найбільшій групі ризику.
Попросіть не виходити з дому.Організуйте для них доставку продуктів, потурбуйтеся про них.
Але якомога менше особистого контакту. Це може зберегти їм життя.
Якщо у вас є перші ознаки захворювання
Висока температура і сухий кашель - це привід, щоб вимагати від закладів охорони здоров’я перевірити вас на наявність коронавірусу.
Стежте за власним станом здоров’я. Якщо у вас підвищена температура і сухий кашель, не будьте легковажними!
Зайдіть на сайт ВОЗ. Там є рекомендації по захисту від коронавірусу багатьма мовами.
Не піддвайтеся паніці і не слухайте чуток
Вірус дуже контагенезний. Він дуже живучий і активно розповсюджується.
Заспокойтеся і бережіть ваше здоров’я